Look at you, you got such a small head!
Big hair, look at him!
Dan has been studying himself,
this video is about a video
that I saw on the internet
where you could actually drop an idiot.
You can drop a swimming
hat onto someone's head
just with the force of
the water that's in it.
So, you know, you get around all the faf
to scraping it down.
Let's see if it works.
Completely unnecessary
this, what he's doing here.
You ready?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Oh, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Oh!
God dammit!
Oh God!
I can't see!
Okay, yeah, it might be easy to apply.
However, not least to apply correctly.
I couldn't exactly start
swimming now, could I?
In like a split second.
That is the quickest time
anyone's ever put a hat
on before, do you think?
Do you think I ever throw
it on the front of your face
it would just engulf your face?
We gotta try that.
Alright, do it again,
but lie on your back.
No, this is stupid!
Put your head down the area.
This is not good.
Look at this!
Ready?
Oh, .
Oh God!
This way a bit.
This way.
How's the angle?
Uh, if get it over my chin,
it's gonna slap me in the face.
If you start to suffocate,
pull it off immediately.
Alright.
Ready?
Yeah.
Oh!
It went down my nose!
There you go, that's
right, there, just go.
Oh!
Oh God, this is awful.
I've decided this isn't going to work.
Yeah, well let's call
it a day on that one,
but the other one was a successful test.
So in this video we learned
that gravity is excellent
at putting on swimming caps,
only on the top of the
head, not the front.
Yeah, don't put a hat on
your face with gravity.
Put it on your head.
Vision slightly impaired.
It's not a great success.
I've got chlorine and hat in my eye.
Well, I hope you enjoyed that video.
Be sure to follow us on Twitter
Yeah, great success,
And subscribe.
See you in the next one.
You wanna go for a dip?
Oh yeah, sure.
This video is brought
to you by audible.com.
If you want to sign up for a
free audio book, use the link
audible.com/slow-mo
there's over 150,000 books.
I recommend "One More Thing" by BJ Novak.
He's very funny.
It's very short.
He was in the office.
That's about it.